thing is and this is the most I'm going
to lose it literally I'm going to lose
it like they bring up his age you bring
up his age he's 80 years old he makes
jokes about his age and yet he's working
on every level foreign and domestically
and then you're you're are you making
the argument is one making the argument
that oh he's 80 therefore a voter is
going to vote for Donald Trump like
that's the choice m m nobody is upset
that the guy is 80 or 81 although as I
brought up on the show yesterday I don't
know anyone I literally do not know one
person and I ask these three guys does
anyone in this room know one person
that's 81 still working a full-time job
obviously such people exist but I don't
know any they don't know any Joe Biden
is obviously not capable of doing the
job but don't and by the way it's not
purely because of his age right it's the
cognitive stuff that is coming along
with his age because you could be 81 and
super fit and super aware and all of th
those things but we know that he is not